[Musik]
jetzt sehen wir aus lesbos also sind
griechischen inseln nahe der türkischen
küste bilder die ein 2015/2016 erinnern
da kommen boote im dutzend pro tag wie
es scheint als würde aus der türkei der
deal nicht mehr ganz richtig halten der
ja hieß die türkei hält die flüchtlinge
versorgt sie und kriegt dafür eine ganze
menge geld aus der europäischen union
haben sie das gefühl da bewegt sich
gerade wieder da braut sich etwas
zusammen was noch einmal sich in einer
flüchtlingskrise ergießen könnte
ausspielen könnte wie 2015 16
ich habe nicht nur das gefühl da braut
sich was zusammen sondern ich habe das
gefühl wir in europa sind teilweise
schuld dass das so ist wenn ich mir
anschaue wie sich die politik in spanien
geändert hat in den letzten jahren
schien in richtung wieder mehr offene
grenzen wenn ich mir anschaue was jetzt
in italien die neue linie jetzt nämlich
wieder offenen höfen und eine umkehr in
der migrationspolitik
dann habe ich schon das gefühl dass die
signale die teilweise aus europa in
richtung afrika in richtung der
schlepper gesamt werden keine sehr
richtigen signale sind was mich positiv
stimmt ist ich habe diese woche mit den
premierministern in bulgarien und in
griechenland telefoniert die sind beide
sehr entschlossen die grenzen zu
schützen sind gegen ein weiter winken
nach mitteleuropa wie dass im jahr 2015
schon einmal der fall war also wenn wir
wollen dann können wir unsere
außengrenzen schon schützen aber ich
glaube es braucht die richtigen signale
und auch einen fokus auf die systeme
sind in die richtigen signale um zum
beispiel zu verhindern hat die türkei
jetzt wieder hunderttausende durchwinkt
es gibt einen deal mit der türkei der
hat uns teures geld gekostet als
europäische union und insofern glaube
ich wäre es sinnvoll wenn wir als
europäische union geschlossen den
präsidenten ernannt vermitteln dass wenn
er sich nicht an diensten deal hell dass
das konsequenzen hat vom abbruch der
beitritt
verhandlungen angefangen was wir schon
lange fordern bis hinauf zu anderen
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen für die
türkei ich glaube wenn wir uns auf sein
spielfeld begeben
und da jetzt wieder mit ihm in
verhandlungen einsteigen
dann werden wir immer mehr an ihn
bezahlen und er wird immer mehr den
eindruck haben und das sind nach art
[Musik]